as we're talking about you know Sam
bankman freed and uh political
corruption this is a big story that's
been that broke yesterday Connecticut
judge overturns results of mayoral
primary just days before election why
because they got evidence on camera of a
Democrat ballot stuffing Wednesday's
ruling is the latest twist in centering
on allegations of absentee ballot abuse
the election captured widespread public
attention after a video surfaced online
appearing to show a supporter of
incumbent mayor Joe gam stuffing stacks
of papers into an absentee ballot
Dropbox I I wonder if uh I think we have
the uh there's a video of it yeah
there's a video so uh this is an image
these are the people that govern you by
the way in these news outlets are they
really do not want to play the video you
got to get the video on Twitter I'll
pull it up in a second but uh here's
what's interesting they're not stopping
the election no this guy won the Primary
they've now overturned the primary
doesn't matter he's still on the ballots
the general election is about to happen
it's presumed he's going to win and they
they speculate that when he does this
will end any challenge to the primary
well with electioneering like that how
could you lose you know it's just crazy
I suppose the answer is you can't
exactly that's that's the game boys
that's what they do they want sorry I
just I just think about like every time
they're like this doesn't happen this is
something the Republicans made up
because there's they're just crazy
they're sad they lost whatever else and
then there's this video of this woman
doing exactly a thing that people fear
and believe happens in their elections
well my favorite narrative is like
everyone when Joe Biden got elected and
everyone's like oh it was totally above
board that stuff never happens and I'm
like you're the same people that were
doing this when Trump won when Bush won
you were talking everyone was talking
about the voting machines when Bush won
I mean you've been doing this for for
decades and now all of a sudden they're
above board entirely there's no election
interference all right I found the video
not even easy to find this video here
you go here's the video that uh
allegedly is of a Democrat ballot
stuffing who is
she um I will'll pull up the name from
the article in a second there and they
have several videos of her doing it by
the way it's not right right this is a
minute and 53 seconds long yeah so uh
let's jump oh they said that she came
back several times yep drop number two
and how many Ballot
Box what's her name they got they got
her name in here too I
think here she goes again this is uh
Wanda Wanda that's all we get I
guess I think we should say her full
name so people know so here's the here's
the crazy thing let me see if it's h in
this article is it
uh uh they don't have it no they don't
have her name in the article uh here
here's here's the thing people need to
understand when Donald Trump and his
supporters were suing over stories like
this it is a lie that they were all
thrown out out right of the uh major I
think the majority of the cases were
were uh thrown out on standing arguing
the individuals who filed the suits did
not have a they were not affected in
this case therefore they had no nothing
to do with the with the contents of the
law which is insane any voter anyone any
citizen in this country has has standing
in my opinion of the the cases I think
there were 30 that were ruled on the
merits 22 were found to be uh in favor
of trump however because in each of
these individual cases either the number
of ballots or some other issues uh for
inance one example is the number of
ballots did not equal a large enough
number to have changed the election it
was ruled moot right it doesn't matter
if we win for you anyway because you
still lost the election but it doesn't
mean there was no election nearing going
on there was certainly fraud Bill bar
said there was fraud the question is was
there enough to overturn the election
the courts were courts said look yes you
found 300 ballots in fraud but there's a
7,000 margin here so what's the point of
this because these courts do not take
action on those it keeps happening and
then what happens when you get 15 judges
in one state and you get 15 instances
where it's 100 votes or I'll say a
thousand and the margin 7,000 and now
there's 15,000 fraudulent bouts
confirmed by courts but because each
individual judge looks at one small
individual individual case they dismiss
all of them right I don't I don't think
that is the the case for the most part
when came to Trump my point is on a
granular granular level we can see
directly local elections are easily
easily flipped with one person doing
something like this and this is Democrat
V Democrat this was a Democratic Primary
in a blue State and they are still
stuffing boxes it's the only reason
we're hearing about it I know but that's
what's interesting this is the thing
that when it happens when when
conservatives or Republicans or third
party candidates say hey we were in some
ways uh there was fraud in our elections
it's typically left leaning candidates
and left leaning supporters who are like
no it never happens but it happens in
their own primaries how can they argue
against this I promise you it's not the
third parties doing it so I just want
everyone to know everyone everyone knows
the Libertarians are the ones secretly
rigging the election for we the ones
rling for Democrats yeah absolutely
we're rigging it for the Democrats well
and the funny thing is is like the
Democrats should be just as worried
about it not just because it's happening
in their own primary but because maybe
Republicans in small towns are doing it
too you know for sure everybody should
be worried about this there's no no
chance that this is isolated event we
know that and like everyone should wake
up and be worried about these things one
of my favorite things in
elections every four years you'll get
conservatives being like if these
Libertarians just voted for the
Republican party then we would have won
and I'm like my guy the Libertarians
don't like you yeah we don't like you at
all Libertarians are like if Republicans
just voted for us we would just win yeah
if you guys just stop voting for this
like deeply entrenched corrupt party
that you'd have a better chance of
changing the NYPD by yourself than you
would of getting like you know 700
people together trying to change the
Republican party at a federal level at
least the Republicans a state and local
can do stuff like my governor and Iowa
has been great on a lot of things you
know but like this this you know there's
a lot of little small like positions
that the Libertarians can win and do win
we win 200 election cycle or something
like that do you feel like the
libertarian party focuses not enough on
the small I've heard this argued before
that it often is like trying to be at
the top of the ticket when really they
should focus on capturing key positions
in our biggest problems is is resources
I mean the national the national party
runs on like 1.7 million a year um they
can't help a a presidential candidate
almost at all presidential candidates
taxed with keeping us ballot access um
raising all their own funds all that
stuff but we do run a lot of down batt
candidates and I think in 2022 with the
misus caucus takeover that became the
bigger Focus was the localization
nullification of you know federal law at
the state and local level and that's the
really important thing that that any
like presidential candidate for the
libertarian party should be doing this
media tour talking about how hey you can
take over your local guns you can take
over your school board you know all
these terrible policies that the schools
are doing you have the opportunity to
run if you got a Tuesday and a Wednesday
free every week you can go run for
Schoolboard you know it's it's not that
hard and you should because even in West
Virginia woke people are masquerading As
Trump supporters to get elected and then
introduce weird crackpot adult content
to kids yeah you should be running you
should be running if you have if you
have two week nights a free a month or
something I mean you could really run
for some of these small positions in
small towns and change everything so
where do you see the most Libertarian
activity in the US like I always think
New Hampshire I've I've interviewed a
couple Libertarians from North Carolina
in the past I can tell you the most
registered uh libertarian voters per
capita is Nebraska um but that's because
New Hampshire like when they did the
free state project they all registered
as Republicans and Democrats to take
over those positions as Republicans and
Democrats so um that's changing now in
New Hampshire of course a lot more
people are joining the libertarian party
there but you know the Happ in Nebraska
they they just have they're pretty
libertarian State I don't know we're
we're in Iowa we're not far behind them
in Iowa as well but we're uh libertarian
party is a national major political
party in Iowa because of our
gubernatorial candidate who ran in the
last election he got a high enough
percentage made us we don't have to
worry about ballot access or anything
like that anymore but now we need a
presidential candidate that can step up
and do those things so that we don't
have to worry about it anymore you need
like 5% right it's there's there's some
speculation it might be a little bit
higher closer to 12% but um it every
State's different is the thing right
like every state has a different
threshold so there's like half the state
over half the states if we were to get
5% we'd never have to worry about ballot
access again at least not for another
four years so um it's an important it's
an important thing you know if you're in
a swing state and you're not worried
about your candidate losing there throw
throw a vote at us let us let's get
seven 7 to 12% you have to register as a
Libertarian in some states some states
are all states are different they all
have different election laws so it just
really depends yeah so what do you
expect going into this cycle I mean
where are you expecting to spend the
most time it's going to be it's going to
be interesting cycle with RFK running
for sure but there's a chance you know
everyone's really worried about RFK but
there's a chance he doesn't get on the
ballot right he's running independent
it's going to cost him millions and
millions and millions of dollars to get
on the ballot in all 50 states he may
get on in a few States but I don't think
he's going to be on the ballot in every
state so it's going to it's not it's not
as big of a deal as some people are
making it out to be but um we're
focusing on 50 states I mean that's
that's the thing we want as many votes
in the popular vote as possible all the
way across the country so that we can
hit like at least a 5% or maybe we do
well enough in the media and we get that
15% in some of the big polls and we can
get on the debate stage cuz that's
really what we want if we can look
Donald Trump and Joe Biden in the eyes
and tell them how bad their policies are
hurting the middle class in America like
that's what we want to do you know cuz
that's what really what this is all
about so that's that's the focus for me
at least my campaign all 50 states no
Foreign Wars no Foreign Wars uh you know
try to dismantle the Federal Reserve as
much as possible of course take down as
many of these federal agencies as we
possibly can um and and VI is right
about this I mean we we can't as a
president you have the power to go out
there and abolish all these federal
agencies but you can lay off 70% of the
workforce or just relocate them to
unalaska well you can you can get rid of
70% then take the last 30% and relocate
them to maintenance departments and mail
rooms at little precincts around the
country and then you know maybe we get
the FBI small enough to where they stop
focusing on trying to infiltrate
Catholic groups and go after uh you know
uh Mexican drug soccer moms at school
board meetings to call them I'm telling
you got I got a plan to revitalize this
country and it's easy how many how many
federal uh uh uh employees are there do
you know oh a lot I don't know it's it's
one of the biggest jobs in the world I I
got an idea all right we'll start with
the FBI how many FBI agents do we got I
don't know I'll look it up to yeah let's
pull up let's pull those numbers you got
the uh FBI ATF you want to abolish the
IRS right well I mean as much as
possible Right the first one the first
one no no don't worry I got a plan uh
how many how many do we got and a clair
I haven't found it yet I'll tell you in
a second enough to infiltrate Catholic
groups no well look look look let's just
they're saying they imply uh 35,000
people but I feel like it's got yeah
it's probably more than here what you do
you don't got to fire them all you don't
got to fire them what you do is you take
1,000 you you you you get 35 units of a
thousand and you relocate them into
rural nowhere places like Central Alaska
I'll tell you why because then Federal
those federal dollars will go towards
creating cities where it will require
the development of Industry right sure
you'll create not only are you going to
force people to live in areas you're
basically colonizing our own country
so you know we got a bunch of stuff in
Alaska we should go up there and and and
re Source our own resources stop working
on China you've never been you've never
been to Alaska in the winter have you I
don't care this is great they can quit
if they want there's a reason why people
don't live there Tim but before you fire
them you say we're going to give you you
know like four more years of employment
but it's going to be in Alaska sure have
a nice day and then when they're there
there's you're going to have to build
housing you're going to have to build
infrastructure then what happens is
these people they need to eat right so
someone's going to open a store
someone's going to open a restaurant
then when you have workers there you
have the opportunity to colonize our own
country instead of seeing our cities die
how about this I was looking at this
City renovo Pennsylvania and I was like
this is a really cool town but it's
dying it was a railway town and uh like
I think like a thousand people live
there just send send send 500 FBI agents
you got to live there now you're
stationed here and then all of a sudden
you're revitalizing that town and giving
these people their jobs back you see
what you see what I'm saying and after
four years you fire room there's a
there's we have give them the full four
years to can we do like one here's my
point here's my point you're basically
using them as a means to help middle
Americans Revitalize their towns and
create some kind of like revitalization
for these areas that need industry and
then you get rid of we're simply not
going to have the funding for that if
they put me 2.87 million Federal
civilian employees in 2022 wow 2 how how
many 2.8 they're like soft Googs it's a
giant well and then and you got to add
to that okay so so that's a huge jobs
program right probably one of the
biggest jobs programs in the world but
then you got to add to that all the
government contracts for people who get
government contracts that's the very
largest employer in the history of the
world maybe ever right so I mean it's
really wild to think about I mean there
is a reason that as the federal
government grew you saw expansion in
Maryland and Northern Virginia right
because other businesses came there so
to Tim's point if we were to say you
know what was it uh the department of
the Interior they moved it to Colorado
under Trump and then under biding their
no no we're going back to DC we don't
want to be here but theoretically if you
were to station these Federal outposts
somewhere else eventually shut it down
or whatever else you're making these
contractors who want these contracts or
want anything else go where they are
they're not just centralizing in DC it's
so crazy to think about that these these
government contracts CU like basically
if you're making a lot of money in
America right now it's probably through
a government contract this is the the
most the biggest employer in the world
and they put that EO Joe Joe uh Joe
Biden put the EO back that said that all
these uh government contracts have to
have a de Dei program you guys know
about that no so like if you're if you
have a government contract with federal
government your company has to have a
Dei Department yep ABS 100% Trump had
ended the EO and Biden brought it right
back and so like when we talk about Dei
and ESG and stuff in America right now
like that's where it's all stemming from
is from the federal government thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net